die Erde ist voller Leben überall egal
ob extrem heiß oder extrem kalt extrem
sauer oder extrem basisch unter extremem
Druck oder in extremer Trockenheit hoch
in der Atmosphäre und tief in der
Erdkruste das Leben
findet einen Weg sogar in den
Reaktorraum 4 in Tschernobyl da gibt es
nämlich einen schwarzen Schimmel der die
für uns tödliche radioaktive Strahlung
einfach als Energiequelle nutzt für die
allerersten Lebewesen wäre sogar dieser
Raum hier den ich persönlich jetzt
gerade eigentlich ganz angenehm finde
ein extremer Lebensraum denn damals war
die Welt noch eine ganz andere wie in
dieser Welt leben aus toter Materie
entstanden sein könnte genau darum geht
es jetzt
übrigens falls ihr auch der Meinung seid
dass es allerhöchste Zeit ist etwas für
die Rettung unseres Planeten vor
Umweltschäden zu tun dann bleibt auf
jeden Fall bis zum Ende dieses Videos
hier dran da habe ich eine sehr
inspirierende videoempfehlung für euch
vor 4,2 Milliarden Jahren war die Erde
steril als sie zuvor mit einem Maß
großen protoplanten kollidiert ist hat
die Hitze des Einschlags die gesamte
Erdkruste schmelzen lassen jegliches
Wasser war verdampft erst schlappe 300
Millionen Jahre später ist es kalt genug
geworden dass der Wasserdampf
kondensieren konnte danach gab es 100
Millionen Jahre lang deutschen Winter
aka ununterbrochen Regen so sind die
Ozeane entstanden und vor 3,7 Milliarden
Jahren war in den Ozeanen auf einmal
Leben auf dieses Alter datiert eine
Studie jedenfalls die ältesten bekannten
Lebensspuren und wenn man dieser Studie
nicht glauben will weil sie ein bisschen
umstritten ist dann sind die ältesten
Spuren von Blaualgen immer noch 3,5
Milliarden Jahre alt und das sind schon
relativ komplexe Lebewesen wie konnte
auf einem sterilen Planeten innerhalb
von diesen 500 bis 700 Millionen Jahren
aus toter Materie Leben entstehen
um die Frage zu beantworten müssen wir
erst einmal Luca kennenlernen das ist
der hypothetisch letzte gemeinsame
Vorfahre aller Lebewesen durch
genetische und biochemische Forschung
wissen wir welche Stoffe die uhrmikrobe
Luca gehabt haben muss und welche
chemischen Reaktionen in ihr abliefen
schon seit geraumer Zeit entwickeln
Forschungsteams Hypothesen die erklären
sollen wie aus toter Materie Luca mit
all sein Bestandteilen geworden ist und
die zwei wichtigsten davon schauen wir
uns jetzt einmal genauer an das
knifflige dabei eine Hypothese
aufzustellen ist dass sich alle Bauteile
in einem Lebewesen gegenseitig bedingen
ohne Erbgut gibt es keine Proteine ohne
Proteine keine Stoffwechselreaktionen
und ohne Stoffwechsel kann er gut und
auch keine Proteine ihr seht wo das
hinführt es ist wie beim Radfahren zum
Losfahren könnte sich ein Fahrrad zuerst
aufs Rad gesetzt haben oder hat zuerst
das Rad angeschoben oder er hat mit
einem Tritt ins Pedal begonnen und genau
so unterscheiden sich die Hypothesen
über den Beginn des Lebens die einen
beginnen mit Proteinen andere mit den
Stoffwechselreaktionen wieder andere
beim Erbgut letzteres ist der Fall bei
der RNA welthypothese sie besagt dass
vor Luca quasi halblebendige Lebewesen
existierten die nur aus RNA bestanden
RNA ist sozusagen die Lawine Schwester
der DNA sie liegt nämlich nicht als
Doppelstrang Helix vor wie die DNA
sondern als Einzelstrang so kann sie
viele Formen annehmen und hat viele
freie Bindungsstellen dank ihrer
nukleotid-sequenz kann RNA als
Erdmaterial dienen wegen der
vielseitigen Struktur und mit Hilfe der
freien Bindungsstellen aber auch als
Enzym oder sogar als gegenschalter
theoretisch ist also eine RNA denkbar
die sich selbst reproduziert und dabei
auch ihr wollt gefunden oder hergestellt
wurde so ein Molekül aber noch nicht als
Beweis für die RNA welthypothese wird
angeführt dass er nah an zentralen
Reaktionen des Lebens beteiligt ist vor
allem bei der Replikation der DNA und
bei der Protein Biosynthese und nein das
heißt nicht das MR na Impfstoffe dann
Erbgut verändern wie die RNA bei
ursprünglich entstanden sein soll daran
scheiden sich nach wie vor die
forschergeistern verschiedene
Reaktionswege sind denkbar aber wenn man
sie in der Natur ablaufen lassen will
erfordern sie teilweise recht
komplizierte Umgebungen die mal feucht
und mal trocken sind das scheint alles
noch sehr wackelig und spekulativ dieses
Problem versucht dagegen die
Hydrothermalquellen Hypothese gleich als
erstes zu lösen Hydrothermalquellen sind
heiße Schlote am Meeresgrund sie
entstehen dort wo Magma relativ nah an
den Meeresboden herankommt und mehr
Wasser tief in das erdgestein sickern
kann
das Wasser wird erhitzt und reagiert
dann mit dem Mineralien im Gestein
wodurch einige nützliche Verbindungen
entstehen insbesondere molekularer
Wasserstoff da eine zentrale Rolle bei
der Energiegewinnung in Zellen spielt
ein Forschungsteam fand heraus dass Luca
etwa 400 Stoffwechselreaktionen gehabt
haben muss das ist nicht besonders viel
bedeutet aber dass sie schon vor Luca da
gewesen sein müssen fast alle dieser 400
Reaktionen nämlich 97% könnten
theoretisch in Hydrothermalquellen von
alleine ablaufen für eine dieser
Reaktionen die pyrobat Synthese wurde
das im Labor Versuch bereits
nachgewiesen und das Erstaunliche dabei
Lebewesen benötigen viele
Reaktionsschritte um pyrowatt
herzustellen unter dem Bedingungen in
der hydrothermalquelle ging das mit nur
einem Schritt
hydrothermarquellen sind also quasi ein
Shortcut hat für leben sie machen das
möglich wofür Lebewesen sonst viele
Enzyme bräuchten die Poren im Gestein
der hydrophanquellen wären also perfekte
Reaktionsräume aus denen die
entstehenden Stoffe nicht entkommen
können sie bleiben eng zusammen und so
können die Stoffwechselreaktionen weiter
ablaufen das ist in lebenden Zellen ja
auch so offene Fragen gibt es bei dieser
Hypothese aber natürlich auch zum
Beispiel wie sich diese Systeme in
Membran in einen Kapseln und ein Erbgut
entwickeln konnten aber die
Hydrothermalquellen Hypothese eröffnet
uns die Möglichkeit neu darüber
nachzudenken wo leben wahrscheinlicher
ist als anderswo sogar in unserem
eigenen Sonnensystem zum Beispiel auf
einem Mond des Saturn
unsere Erde umkreist die Sonne in einer
Entfernung die flüssiges Wasser auf der
Oberfläche erlaubt und weil alle
Hypothesen zu Entstehung des Lebens
flüssiges Wasser voraussetzen bezeichnet
man diese Zone als bewohnbar neben
Sternenlicht gibt es aber noch andere
Energiequellen die Wasser flüssig halten
können der Mond entsalatus wird zum
Beispiel durch Gezeitenkräfte von innen
aufgewärmt an einem seiner Pole schießt
Wasser aus seiner mehrere Kilometer
dicken Eiskruste der Grund könnte ein
riesiger Ozean sein der unter der
Eisdecke den ganzen Mond umspannt die
Cassini Mission hat Proben von dem
Wasser analysiert dass da aus der
Oberfläche schießt das Ergebnis lässt
auf Hydrothermalquellen schließen und
wenn man der Hydro vermeiden Hypothese
folgt heißt das dass dort Leben
entstehen könnte außerhalb der
bewohnbaren Zone und sogar ganz ohne
Licht
auch der Jupitermond Europa könnte einen
Ozean aus flüssigem Wasser mit
Hydrothermalquellen beherbergen deshalb
bereitet man sich bei der NASA darauf
vor Sonden zu den beiden eismonten zu
schicken um dort nach Leben zu suchen
und auch auf dem Mars könnte von langer
Zeit leben in Hydrothermalquellen
entstanden sein Wasser und
Eisenmineralien gibt es dort ja und
passivierens so fleißig nach Spuren aber
was ist mit den Planeten zu denen wir
keine Sonnen schicken können
auch da können wir vom Leben auf der
Erde lernen das Leben hat die Erde
nämlich schon ziemlich früh ziemlich
stark verändert als die Blaualgen die
Fotosynthese erfanden produzierten sie
Unmengen an Sauerstoff so viel das erst
alles oxidiert wurde was oxidiert werden
konnte und dann auch noch die Atmosphäre
mit Sauerstoff angereichert wurde heute
besteht die Luft die wir gerade Atmen zu
über 20% auf Sauerstoff ohne dieses
Leben wäre da gar kein Sauerstoff
wenn es in der Atmosphäre eines fremden
Planeten also einen Stoff gibt der dort
eigentlich nicht von selbst entstehen
kann dann hat man vielleicht potenziell
möglicherweise einen Biomarker also ein
Anzeichen für Leben entdeckt und die
Atmosphäre von Planeten können wir mit
Hilfe des Lichtspektrums untersuchen das
uns von dort erreicht ihr habt
vielleicht gehört dass ein Forscherteam
auf diese Weise in der Atmosphäre der
Venus phosphine entdeckt haben will
einige Forscherinnen und Forscher
glauben dass fossilen auf der Venus ein
Biomarker sein könnte andere sind sich
da nicht so sicher bei einer Entdeckung
solcher Tragweite sollte man natürlich
auch immer möglichst skeptisch sein
außergewöhnliche Behauptungen benötigen
außergewöhnlich gute Beweise trotzdem
wird schon spekuliert wie Leben in den
oberen Schichten der vinosianischen
Atmosphäre aussehen könnte
[Musik]
ich finde es super spannend darüber zu
spekulieren wie das Leben auf der Erde
entstanden sein könnte es ist immerhin
der Anfang von uns allem aber es wird
wahrscheinlich auch immer eine
Spekulation bleiben wir können ja leider
nicht 4 Milliarden Jahre in die
Vergangenheit reisen ziemlich sicher ist
wohl dass das Leben für seine Entstehung
einen felsigen Himmelskörper mit
flüssigem Wasser und eine Energiequelle
benötigt und die Hydrothermalquellen
Hypothese zeigt uns dass die Energie
nicht von der Sonne kommen muss so
kommen neue Orte für die Entstehung von
Leben in Frage sollten die Expeditionen
zu enzillardos und Europa leben finden
wäre das vielleicht die Bestätigung der
Hydrothermalquellen Hypothese und eine
Sensation die die Weltsicht vieler
Menschen auf den Kopf stellen dürfte
okay jetzt kommt die inspirierende
videoempfehlung für all diejenigen den
der Schutz unseres Planeten genauso am
Herzen liegt wie mir die Wilding
Organisation Planet wild veröffentlicht
jeden Monat ein neues Video um unseren
Planeten zu renaturieren und die Schäden
zu beheben die die Menschen der Natur
zufügen und das alles wird von einer
Community finanziert der jeder beitreten
kann der unserem Planeten helfen möchte
sich zu erholen ich selbst bin Teil
davon weil ich es unglaublich gut und
wichtig finde etwas unternehmen wirklich
etwas zu machen und nicht nur darüber zu
reden in diesem Video verwandeln Sie
einen riesigen Sterbenden Wald in ein
klimaresistentes Ökosystem und in diesem
hier retten sie den süßesten Vogel
Europas vor dem Aussterben die Blend
wild Videos sind wirklich einzigartig es
geht sowohl um effektiven Umweltschutz
als auch um spannendes Hintergrundwissen
und Unterhaltung das ist eine sehr coole
Kombi also schaut euch jetzt unbedingt
die Planet Videos an und wie immer
bleibt neugierig euer Cedric